- Welcome back y'all we've
got Tiffany Haddish dialed in,
give it up for her.
(audience applauding)
So we're celebrating
Rad Mamas all week long
and Tiffany's new kid's book
is perfect for all you mamas.
It's called "Layla the Last Black Unicorn".
I love it.
The colorful cause my kids love color.
It's a great story that comes
with some very cool illustrations.
It reminded us of a segment we like to do
at the show for guests
who have stories so epic
there's just not enough
time to tell them properly.
So just so happens.
Tiffany is one of those guests
with one of those stories.
So we now bring you another
installment of Epic Story Time
(upbeat music)
- ♪Epic story time. ♪
(audience applauding)
- All right. So with this
segment I ask one question
and Tiffany will tell
us an epic story backed
by a bunch of illustrations.
As always I'll have some
follow up questions at the end
but here's my one question
to get us started.
All right.
Hey Tiffany, it's Rad
Mama week at the show.
Have you ever thought about motherhood?
- Well, I definitely have thought about it
which leads me to a really amazing story.
Let me tell you.
(Kelly laughing)
This story is how I ended up with a baby
in a bed with me one morning okay.
It all started when I was on a date
we had a very good time.
We were talking and laughing
and drinking wine all evening.
Like I said, it was a very good time.
So we was feeling ourselves, right.
(Kelly laughing)
And at what point during the
day the guy got all serious
and he leaned in and asked me,
"are you interested in
having kids in the future?"
And at that moment I was
thinking, thank Lord,
I remember to take my birth control, okay.
(audience laughing)
But, I said to him very casually,
"whatever God has planned
for me is what it is,
maybe in the next two and three years
maybe five years from now.
Otherwise I'm not that
interested in this exact moment."
(audience laughing)
So after the date, the guy drops me off
and kisses me at the front door
and it's a very romantic,
lovely little kiss.
And I went inside and at that moment
I was supposed to call my sister
but it was around midnight
and I was exhausted and
I had been drinking.
So I just went ahead
and went to bed, okay.
(audience laughing)
I went right to sleep, fell asleep.
When I woke up the next
morning, I felt great.
I was feeling really good.
And then what was, something's crying?
I look over and there's a
baby on the bed lying right
next to me. What the hell!
Who put this baby on my bed?
I start freaking out, like,
when did I have a baby?
Oh my gosh am I two to
five years in the future?
(audience laughing)
Then I have a baby and I
don't remember having a baby.
I don't feel no baby pains
My stomach ain't small.
Where did the baby come from?
Am I still dreaming?
Maybe I'm dreaming about this baby
cause the baby looked just like me.
Is this my baby?
I called my sister.
I said, "girl, there's a baby in my bed.
I don't know how this baby got in my bed.
I don't know where this baby
came from it look just like me.
What year is this?"
She said, "girl, it's 2016."
I said, "oh, okay but okay,
well, 2016 when I went to sleep
with, where I got a baby"
she said, "what'd the baby look like?"
I started describing the baby.
She said, "girl, that's Jasmine, baby."
That's my other sister.
(audience laughing)
So I called my sister Jasmine,
"Jasmine how'd your baby get in my bed?"
And she said, "you and the baby okay".
I said, "yeah, we fine but how
did the baby get in my bed?"
She said, "I came over about
one o'clock you said, yeah,
the baby can stay here.
I have to be at work."
I said, "oh, okay oh,
you gotta be at work.
But I gotta a job too.
You know, I have to work too."
So I was working on the
Carmichael show at that time
and I had to take this
baby to work with me.
I took the baby to work with me.
I had her sitting right
next to me during the
table read and during rehearsals.
And you know we did our table read
and everybody was looking like
why does Tiffany have this baby here?
But I didn't say nothing.
I just kept going through with my scene
and everything finished the table read.
And then I stood up and I said
"I have an announcement to make everyone,
this is not my baby."
(audience laughing)
- Which then
- This is my niece.
I'm babysitting.
(audience laughing)
And I was bringing her to work every week
with me till my sister lost her job.
The end.
(audience laughing)
- Until my sister job.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God.
Please tell me that you (beep)
you had a pause when you said,
"hey guys, this isn't my baby."
Like people were like,
"whose baby do you have?"
Like, please tell me you left a pause
before you said, "it's my niece."
(both laughing)
- I did pause.
It was so funny because like,
everybody was like, what?
Like they were whispering to each other.
And I wasn't saying anything about it.
I wasn't talking, like I
was acting it's normal to
bring a baby to work, you know,
on the movie set.
- I love that you didn't say anything.
- And I gave her her bottle.
She was chill. My niece is cool.
She's just like me.
She's all about entertainment.
You know, she was laughing
at all my jokes in the scene.
I was loving her.
I was like, yeah, I need
her to be here all the time.
She was only like five months too.
She was a little baby.
She should not have been there.
- Oh my God.
Thank you for your epic story, Tiffany.
(audience applauding)
That was awesome.
And a big, thanks to Marcel
Asevedo in our department
in our art department, he is amazing.
He did all those illustrations.
He's so talented.
And there's so funny.
Tiffany's kids' book is
"Layla, the Last Black Unicorn".
Y'all gotta go pick it up and
her movie it's so funny y'all,
it's so good, "The Unbearable
Weight of Massive Talent".
They're both out right now.
So go check 'em out.